leroux bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors votre organisation fait
partie des signataires de cette tribune
vous dénoncé une violation flagrante du
droit international
une annexion qui pourrait d'ailleurs
sonné le glas de la solution à deux
états alors au delà de ce que vous
attendez concrètement de la part de la
france et de l'union européenne
oui bonjour cette tribune s'intitule
agir pour empêcher une nouvelle annexion
donc il y a le terme agir qui est très
important puisque aujourd'hui face à la
menace sérieuse d'annexion qui sont
envisagées par le gouvernement israélien
à partir du 1er juillet il faut vraiment
agir il faut pas se contenter de
déclarations de d'indiquer que nous
regrettons que nous sommes pas d'accord
il faut agir il ya des moyens pour agir
il ya des moyens pour agir par des
mesures de rétorsion qui sont possibles
notamment par l'interdiction des
produits des colonies par le rappel des
ambassadeurs par différentes
possibilités de d'action c'est un
conflit qui dure depuis des années
on sait bien le conflit israélo
palestinien et puis on voit bien que
israël voilà agrandit son territoire
au fur et à mesure des années qui
passent avec également le soutien des
états unis qui sont qui qui soutiennent
directement le gouvernement de tel-aviv
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la politique de la
france doit changer totalement un ce que
je disais tout à l'heure
jusque là la france et l'europe souvent
se contente de regretter les initiatives
israéliennes de colonisation
un exemple récent en février monsieur
netanyahou a annoncé donc le premier
ministre israélien l'extension de
l'autorisation de construction de
logements dans une zone jugée
stratégique par y compris par la france
et l'europe et il n'y a pas aucune
il n'y a eu aucune mesure de rétorsion
face à cette annonce qui autorisait donc
3401 logements supplémentaires dans la
zone e1 faut savoir que le la
colonisation est un prélude à l'annexion
et que c'est un long processus qui dure
depuis 67 notamment avec l'annexion de
jérusalem est qui a eu lieu en 81 et
quand je dis jérusalem est
jérusalem est étendue aux portes de
ramallah au nord et à bethléem au sud
est donc cette cette première annexion
de jérusalem est s'est faite dans la
punit télé plus totale donc nous avons
habitués le gouvernement les
gouvernements israéliens successifs à
une impunité et donc ça c'est
intolérable parce que c'est contraire au
droit international contraire à la paix
et ça crée des précédents dans le monde
entier alors on parle de cette annexion
qui qui risque d'être confirmé le 1er
juillet on sait que donald trump a
élaboré un plan également un plan
voilà pour faire d'israël le grand
israël avec avec benyamin nétanyahou
si jamais voilà l'élection est vraiment
confirmé au 1er juillet quels seront les
les conséquences sur la vie des
palestiniens et plus généralement sur le
proche orient
allez les consoles les conséquences
peuvent être désastreuses les pays
limitrophes d'ailleurs notamment la
jordanie se sont alertés de cette manne
annexion ça risque de déstabiliser le
proche orient et puis c'est d'abord les
palestiniens qui vont en faire les frais
notamment les palestiniens qui seront
dans les zones annexées puisqu'il y a
plus de cent cinquante mille
palestiniens dans ces zones et il donne
et deviendront étrangers dans leur
propre pays ce qui est incroyable
ils n'auront même pas le permis de
résidence puisque les autorités
israéliennes ont indiqué qu' il n'était
pas du tout intégré dans les voilà donc
ça c'est pas normal
alors aujourd'hui il ya un mouvement à
la fois chez les palestiniens dans le
monde arabe dans le monde entier contre
cette annexion donc on espère qu'elle
n'aura pas lieu en france donc aussi une
mobilisation
la société civile que nous représentons
en france avec 7
cette tribune initiée par la plate forme
des ong par la palestine et qui
rassemble 33 signataires dont des
signataires très important des trois
syndicats majeur en france notamment et
il ya une montée de la de la
contestation de cette annexion
chez aussi les parlementaires et donc on
espère qu'elle va pas se faire mais si
elle ne se fait pas parce que le
gouvernement israélien peut reculer
il faut dénoncer l'annexion de facto qui
se réalise sur le terrain tous les jours
il y aura peut-être pas de si on espère
qu'il y aura pas d'annexion deux jurés
mais l'annexion de de facto est presque
aussi dangereuse et il faut absolument
la combattre et la france et l'europe
ont les moyens de la combattre par des
mesures de rétorsion l'embargo sur les
produits des colonies par exemple des
mesures de rétorsion sur notamment des
désaccords divers et variés avec israël
qui est donc une puissance occupante et
qui annexe
donc nous avons les moyens de prendre
des mesures pour faire céder
l'entreprise d'annexion israélienne
merci beaucoup
françois leroux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de la plateforme des ong
françaises pour la palestine